حطام القصيره الامريكيه تشغل بالروسيه
والغرب حاليا الاخيره ارسلت طائرات
امريكيه واوروبيه لمسح منطقه السقوط املا
بايجاد بقايا لتلك المسيره ولكن ما هي
هويه هذه المسيره التي اشعلت سجالا بين
القوتين العظمتين واوضحت هنا واشنطن انها
مسيره تقوم بعمليات روتينيه في المجال
الجوي الدولي المسيره هي من نوع ام كيو 9
وهي طائره استطلاع تستخدمها القوات الجويه
الامريكيه لجمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
واجراء مهام المراقبه والبحث والانقاذ
والضربات الدقيقه على اهداف عاليه القيمه
والحساسيه يمكن لهذه الطائره حمل ثمانيه
صواريخ موجهه بالليزر و16 صاروخا من طراز
هل فاير وهذا يسمح لها بالتحليق في الهواء
لمسافه تصل
1850 كم والطيران على ارتفاع يصل الى 50
الف قدم ام كيوناين تعتبر العمود الفقري
لاسطول الاستطلاع الجوي للجيش الامريكي
وتبلغ تكلفتها حوالي 30 مليون دولار لكن
مشاهدينا ومقابل كل هذه المواصفات
والقدرات الا ان هذه المسيره تمتلك عيبا
تجعل منها هدفا جويا سهلا وعرض مكشوفه
لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي فهذه المسيره قامت
بمهام فوق العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى طبعا ويتم تشغيلها عن بعد بواسطه
فريقين من قاعدتين من اصل 20 قاعده في
سبعه عشره ولايه
[موسيقى]
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه سرعتها تصل الى 300 كيلو مترا في
الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نحو 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه